I have the hosts of game SWAT zone dead
air podcast or co-host Mary Kish and
Jacob Decker
I'm not the one you wanna guess you're a
regular guest enough to be a co-host
might as well be on Mike McCarty the
regular host he's not here you're stuck
with the day he's dead you're stuck with
the cheap version of Mike McCarty and
you dress nicer than him oh I'm handsome
right
but you guys talk about horror movies
and entertainment a lot but I wanted to
talk about our scariest gaming moments
it is game spot and it is Halloween Jake
did you want to kick it off what was
your what's been your scariest gaming
moment so the first thing that came to
mind was Petey but I think that one I
took that yes then this I think this
one's kind of unconventional it's
Resident Evil 4 that was scary I know
it's kind of when they kind of stop
shifting away from scary but I think I
was like 12 at the time and it looked
very real at the time and like I'll
never forget when you first hear that
chainsaw revving and you said you see
that guy show up and then he what's Leon
just gets his head cut off if you like
mess up it was it was boring
sorry like 12 I don't think you were old
enough to play that game no that was a
cool parents you better you had a friend
with a friend I'd go over to his house
and we we'd play but that game it was
very like atmospheric like even that
like was just creepy just walking down
and like hearing the zombies not really
zombies talk to you or scream in
different languages that was the
pinnacle of when like the QuickTime
QuickTime ish movements were like really
effective because they weren't all the
time and that it was like right when it
was like these peak amount of scare and
so if you didn't do them on time because
you were freaking out it resulted in
your death which was these like really
rad cutscenes that upset you greatly so
they just did a really good blend of
that and res for ya and as you mentioned
that was kind of the transition away
from more horror focused resident evils
into more of a shooter focused game yeah
especially near the end of that game but
the beginning is like that bad scared me
especially you've like even when you
first walk into that house and you just
see that guy stare
off into the corner and you're like hey
how's it going and then he jumps you and
it's like okay this is not okay
hopefully they bring that back for
Resident Evil seven that mix of horror
that we got kind of with the original
Resident Evil and then that we saw in
the beginning of Resident Evil 4 was rez
for also the first over-the-shoulder
yeah where they kind of changed at the
camera angle so you're not controlling a
tank that's right which was great for
the controls but also cinematically it
really helps put you in perspective that
you are that person that's in danger
much more than an over-the-shoulder or
like a security cam perspective could
ever do when you're right over their
shoulder it gives you just this horrible
angle of something that's coming at you
really fast
that's something that sometimes worked
really well for the Resident Evil games
that they had those really weird camera
angles it was annoying to control but
that let them control what you were
going to see so that something could be
coming out and you or something could be
around a corner and you can't see it
because of the way the cameras which is
frustrating but also frightening well
Mary what was what's been your scariest
gaming moment yeah I mean I've played a
lot of scary games are you guys
including Petey but I would have to say
that the scariest game I've ever played
and including that moment is amnesia
there's multiple moments and amnesia
that's really really upsetting but
there's there's a lot of a deaf blend of
puzzles and horror anime where you're
you're going it's called the Dark
Descent I don't want to get it mixed up
with the machine for pigs which is kind
of like a sequel but it was made by a
different company so the Dark Descent is
about a slow descent from a mansion
learning about this kind of crazy dude
and I don't get too much in this story
but there's these creatures and what's
brilliant I think about this game is
much like Petey you cannot fight you can
only run or hide and your vision and the
audio gets disoriented if you see a
monster so anytime let's say you're like
focusing on a puzzle there's this one we
were kind of like turning all these
different handles to kind of get pipes
working and as soon as you solve it a
monster enters this area it kind of
looks like a winery there's like all
these giant barrels
you have to hide behind these barrels
but you can see it coming behind the
barrels and your ducking and your vision
gets really blurry and there's a very
distinct sound effect that I can't make
are you sure yeah it's a teeth grinding
possibly possibly like breaking a little
bit and it's really it's really
upsetting and so you're basically hiding
you're obscuring your vision and you're
hiding and you can hear it and you can
hear the teeth breaking and you want to
freak out and you do and sometimes they
do catch you and it's absolutely in in
the history because like I was I mean I
didn't play it when it first came out I
played it when I was older and I just
like remember I couldn't I couldn't beat
it I didn't want to put it on I got to
the point where like I wouldn't put my
headphones on and I I thought like I had
to read a book two hours before I went
to bed because I had nightmares about it
it is to this day it is the
quintessential scariest game that I've
ever played I think it is like the one
if someone says what game should I play
if I want to actually like piss myself
it's like that's the one you want
amnesia that one will will break you do
you know that from personal experience I
peed myself register well the thing that
I think that makes it so effective is
that you're not able to fight back and
that's what makes frightening games so
frightening Resident Evil is less scary
because you have a gun you have a way to
fight back and chop them so I actually
played amnesia and I think the reason it
wasn't there was because I played like
20 minutes of it and I was like no no no
this is this is not gonna do this to
myself they on purpose also you have a
lantern they don't give you enough oil
and they don't give you enough matches
that you're just constantly suffering so
it's almost singing yeah it's like they
give you not enough and I mean it like
you know some games they're like it's
not enough to have the lantern the whole
time this isn't enough to have a lantern
a third of the time like you were
constantly suffering and much like in
real life
your vision gets better if you don't
have it over time so you can see better
in the dark if you just don't have a
lantern over time you'll adjust the game
kind of adjusts for you
but that's so unfair
you're just constantly having to go into
the dark and they really mess with you a
great deal
you can light candles but there's not
enough matches they just the whole thing
is just a giant troll and trying to
mentally screw with you you know you're
playing with lights is is atrophic I
think at a lot of games where they give
you just enough there's one in
particular that stands up called The
Grudge ennui ennui which we wouldn't
think was a very scary game it was based
on the the Japanese films and it was a
really it's basically a haunted house
experience where you're walking around
with a flashlight that is constantly
losing batteries and it's just you you
walk along you walk at a snail's pace
you can't run you can only look around
and it's just horrible intense I think
of the we the quintessential console for
more ethically it was just frightening I
think of like that reminds me a lot of
condemned criminal origins I remember
that was like one of the first games
I've played I'm sure there are more but
we're like you to actually run out of
batteries for your flashlight and being
young at the time too and like my
batteries would run out I'd pause and be
like I'm done that's it yeah I quit this
game multiple times there are certain
games where it it breaks you you
actually can't do it but you have to
commit right so and I found this similar
to PT and Resident Evil is like if you
take off your headphones you play in at
like a well-lit room or something you're
gonna get through it but you're ruining
it for yourself if you dim the lights if
you put on good headphones and you
immerse yourself like you are asking for
it and these are the games that will
shake you yeah for me PT is is the
scariest experience I've ever played
like I think a lot of those other games
are scary but it's more stressful period
it more puts me on edge and it makes me
tired
whereas PT is one of like I literally
think it's the first game where I was
playing it and the jump-scare got me so
good that I screamed and dropped the
controller and I was so embarrassed that
I just did that which moment are you
talking so for me it was the specific
moment when you're walking down the hall
and you're like everything's pretty okay
and then you see the thing down the hall
you're like oh this is this is gonna be
bad I look away and you look back and
she's just flying down the hallway at
you
and grabs you Mike I can't believe you
got me and I just literally screamed
yeah that's a very good - I think the
one coming up which is like the one that
most people remember is there's a part
where the phone you or you're like
listening to an answering machine or
something and there's someone listening
to a bunch of numbers and then right as
that happens the woman grabs you grabs
your face and kind of like gets right up
in that screen and I I don't see how
anyone can get through that without
making at least a little beep noise come
out of them in some way I am stoic in in
horror games oh yeah so good like that
face is so good I try to be stoic like
there was a stream that we did we played
Slenderman I'm like I'm not gonna react
at all I'd like to not react in these
kind of games and I honestly couldn't do
with Petey and another reason I think it
does that is because even though you
don't see a lot of things you don't go
to a lot of places it's rendered so good
it looks so good you know it's amazing
about horror games - as you can get away
with a lot that doesn't always look that
great - like for example like the Petey
villain this woman often she's obscured
she's obscured like she's outside of the
window or she's like in the rafters or
she's coming at you so quickly you can't
really see her and that part of that is
the fear that you don't really know what
you're looking at it's quite the same
with amnesia those monsters if you if I
asked you to draw it you probably have a
hard time doing it kind of looks like a
skinny boogeyman from The Nightmare
Before Christmas it's like this like
little sack with the eyes and I don't
even know like it's hard to describe but
that's what makes this so upsetting it's
because you don't you don't really know
what's coming after you that that
mystery and then playing a lot with your
screen and one of my favorite horror
games of all time was eternal darkness
where you had an insanity meter and the
beginning parts of that game I thought
it would it got less fun towards the end
because you became really powerful but
in the beginning just weird stuff what
happened you had no control over it your
your screen would be inverted or things
would be coming at you and Petey kind of
did that as well especially as you get
later in the game the the world starts
changing around you and you have no cut
you don't feel like you have
anymore the whole PT experience from
beginning to end is is really meant to
mess with you mentally and I love the
fact that it all takes place within one
hallway and people were dissecting this
game because it was so scary everyone
wanted to understand the psychology
behind it and one of the interesting
things that I heard was if you recall
because you're going in a circle
basically but you never go upstairs you
only go downstairs at the very end of
the hallway and then you open the door
and you're at the beginning of the
hallway again and so basically what what
it's essentially saying is that you're
going down and down and down
into hell and the more loops that you go
is scarier it gets and so this is this
is just like one of the things that the
game is kind of subconsciously doing to
the players which is just making you
feel like you are totally just walking
towards your do it's really really well
done from beginning to end yeah we might
have to revisit some of these games as
we get closer to Halloween but a merry
you're also working on some upcoming
really good horror games are there any
you can tease us with I mean yeah
there's gonna be a lot of really cool
content on GameSpot for Halloween
because it's like our favorite time for
scary game so we're gonna do upcoming
scariest games that we could find you
know you know outlast 2 is gonna be on
there and there's a few secret ones that
we found recently that I think are gonna
be really exciting for people to
discover so they're definitely want to
check that out and then dead air it's
gonna do a few episodes based on like
the scariest games or the scariest games
ever in the past and then games to come
in the future I think we might even
tease some like VR and oculus scary
games so basically if you're like into
scary games or just you know being
scared silly and any kind of experience
whether that be games or books or movies
Dead airs is where you're gonna find all
that creepy stuff mmm well Mary Jake
thanks so much for joining us those are
the hosts of our dead air horror
podcasts what were your scariest gaming
moments let us know in the comments
below we'd love to hear more about them